someone once said that life is just one
decision after another and I agree some
decisions are small like what to wear
but some are so big they'll affect us
for decades to come
like choosing a career when I'm facing a
big decision I make sure I do three
things free up my brain's bandwidth give
it the fuel it needs and get honest
advice from her friends by eliminating
the small choices in life you save the
best of your brain's ability for the
really important things when he was an
office Barack Obama removed one decision
from his daily life what to wear it was
always a grey or blue suit and a white
shirt because he knew the science behind
decision making and that by wearing a
kind of uniform
he'd say found wit for the really
important choices scientists studying
the brain have seen that all decisions
big or small consume the same amount of
energy a small decision takes the same
amount of energy as a big one so when
you need to make really important
decisions like which university to apply
to all which job offer to accept be
vigilant about not wasting energy on
decisions that aren't going to make a
massive difference to a life save your
brains bandwidth for things that really
matter your brain needs fuel to think
just as much as your body does to move
thanks to advanced imaging we can watch
the brain working away more clearly than
ever before it's the most complex and
energy demanding organ we have if you're
very hungry neurotransmitters can't be
produced which results in communication
between the brains 86 billion neurons
breaking down
compromising your ability to think and
make good decisions so when you need to
make an important decision make sure
you're not hungry
and I don't mean reach for the biscuit
in research shows are drinking plenty of
water and having a slow-release
carbohydrate breakfast like porridge
will help you think clearly omega-3 is
also a brilliant brain feed you can find
it in oily fish and pumpkin and
sunflower seeds it doesn't mean you
can't treat yourself but do try to give
your brain of this kind of fuel tea the
final step is to stop the fear of loss
dominating your decision-making Nobel
laureate Daniel Kahneman spent a decade
studying human decision-making and found
that in big decisions were generally
more afraid of loss than we are
motivated by gain according to his
research this means we often pick the
safest option rather than the one that
will have the most positive impact on
our lives car Nimmons got a great tip
for getting over this fear of loss ask
the advice of a friend who's not afraid
to drop some truth bombs even if it
means your feelings get a bit roughed up
an objective friend can help you
identify the best decision because
they're not weighed down by the fear of
what could be lost in the end the
decision is always your's but it helps
to seek this kind of advice so the next
time you're facing a big decision free
your brain from straw decisions give it
really good fuel and seek out a friend
who cares more about your future than
your feelings thanks for watching don't
forget to subscribe and click the bail
to receive notifications for new videos
see you again soon